we begin this morning with breaking news
out of downtown las vegas where a large
fire has destroyed several buildings and
injuring one person this happened on
fremont and tower street that's just
west of eastern at one o'clock this
morning las vegas fire and rescue is
currently on scene continuing to put out
hot spots between four to seven
buildings are completely destroyed a few
of those are condos around two dozen
cars were also scorched in the fire
officials say the first building that
went up in flames was a unit that was
under construction nearly 50 units and
150 firefighters were called there to
that scene now let's go ahead and take a
live look here from the traffic cam at
charleston the fire is mostly knocked
down but it's not completely out just
yet they tell us up to 100 people are
still out of their homes now on this
camera on the left hand side is
charleston on the right is is uh fremont
you can still see the emergency vehicles
uh they're blocking fremont street and a
couple of them on charleston as well
it's in between those two there's a
block of condominiums the evacuation
center has been opening up at
hollingsworth elementary school for
those who are out of their homes red
cross is also helping those evacuated
crews remain there on scene to continue
the investigation now the public
information officer from las vegas fire
and rescue tells me this might be the
largest fire he has battled in his 26
years there with the department again up
to seven buildings destroyed in this
place one person has injured a minor
injury
associated with that but fire crews say
that this appeared to have started in
one of those buildings that was under
construction they are continuing
to find out what exactly caused this and
of course we have crews there on scene
gathering some information for you we'll
continue to update you on this story
throughout our newscast and online